first of all a pleasure to see you again
and I feel like I just saw you like
yesterday ah in London yes I was like
three days ago yes
literally uh well I think we're gonna
say something no I was just well I
didn't realize you just came back this
soon yeah well I just got back we did
the whole given black thing clever yes
but you know he's in a lot of things he
has to keep on promoting it stuff like
wow talk about it I mean he's the one
who's in everything oh my god he just
said Avengers he is distant here's
another like lemon Avengers for like to
say uh first I want to start by saying
you guys are fantastic together I you
guys made me laugh a ton last night I I
say thank you sincerely no thank you um
what is it like the night before you
guys are going to meet for the first
time like for chemistry or to talk about
the project what is it like the night
before are you and your head a little
bit like hey I really hope we get along
or you know what I mean I wasn't I
wasn't concerned about that I was really
excited to meet Camille I think it was a
it was pure excitement to meet him I was
the night before I was stressed about
all kinds of other stuff too I'm always
stressed for auditions or chemistry
tests because it's just they're just
uncomfortable but I had a lot going on
and I travelled in the night before to
uh to do this yeah Kenneth Faried was
like early on a Saturday was there 8
a.m. on a Saturday or something and so I
was not nervous to meet Dave I was
excited to meet Dave I knew it that we'd
get along we have friends in common but
I was just nervous as he said even
though they're not auditioning anyone
else it's still nerve-racking it's
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable but we
were uncomfortable together yeah yeah I
think that's what that helped us connect
me and you and when you start talking
openly like we were trying to do that
like felt to me in the chemistry read it
just felt so awkward and difficult cos
you're in a room pretending to be
whatever and then when we shot that
scene it was like the easiest thing in
the world because we'd like done it in
the worst possible situation so then
doing it in the real place was a breeze
what do you see you you can look back on
the project now what do you wish you
knew on day one
before like basically your first day of
filming if anything I I don't know about
knowing I think it's just for me it just
it I need a grace period to actually to
just find myself in this character I
don't know I don't feel like I'm really
in a groove until a week or so in so I'm
always really self-conscious about what
I do like early on in the filling up
every film that I do I feel like I could
have go back and look and I knew I know
it seems I shot early and I will be
uncomfortable because I know later on
the film I was much more comfortable in
the character except for dry strikes now
is just used to put on dress yeah for me
I wish I'd known how difficult like
action acting is and all physical acting
of that nature I wish I'd known I would
have prepared more for it because I
really did not go in I I what I would
have like been in better shape for it
and this was like well the thing is like
this is your first action good shape he
actually I wasn't
yeah he pulled up his sleeve one day and
flex his bicep and I was so impressed
that I took a picture of it yeah I don't
know he's talking about
um I've spoken to a lot of actors and
they talked about having a pre shooting
ritual like before the camera rolls
they're in their head they're doing
something listening to music for each of
you do you do anything before you start
filming I'm most like unprepared I don't
I don't I don't I try to stay out of my
head and try not to I don't get all
wrapped up in like rehearsing stuff in
my head not even what the lines age I
kind of I want to know what the gist of
the scene is just the conversation is
but I'll find it as we go which usually
so it makes it seem as I'm that I'm very
unprepared and I usually a.m. because I
like to find the scene I like to groove
and you know get into a groove and he's
my way into it
yeah I really am the opposite I go in
like I really it makes me less nervous
if I at least have a version of what the
scene is like and then that actually
makes me more flexible I can change and
work with the other person
but for me the preface I don't listen to
music or anything I just want to be
loose and talking to people then I don't
like it when right before
see none cooped up somewhere you know I
want to be like interacting with people
and I want to feel like myself yeah I
definitely have to ask because I
realized something this morning um
there's a lot of talk that you could be
joining the Marvel Universe has pet has
he given you any advice I can't I mean I
don't even go there you know I don't
know if I can you should ask them about
it I understand at some point in the
upcoming future I will reassess question
yeah and come back to it can you want to
ask actually uh what I'm gonna ask a few
fun questions what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once x-files I've done it so many times
I've seen that show the most what is it
what is this sign phone yeah it's great
though we can't I can't I just don't get
tired of it yeah no it holds up and
stuff is there anything that you collect
[Laughter]
watches I collect lunchboxes he has how
many would you have hundreds I've got
hundreds yeah well like this old lunch
boxes with the thermos yeah yeah he just
got like this one that he'd been hunting
for for a long he just got it a month
ago I got ya I got just like a 1950's
toppy lunchbox which was like impossible
to get Alya ta couldn't buy it you had
to get it through trading stamps and
most people don't even know what trading
stamps are anymore
but anyway so I got this lunchbox but
the funny story is because so we did
South by Southwest and I had a neck
issue and I had to cancel it's the first
time I've ever had to cancel some of my
press stuff and then we were done where
was it we did something else it was for
a screening we didn't Dallas yeah and I
was running late and he sends me a text
and he says dude he said dude if uh if
you blow us off I'm gonna [ __ ] in your
tux like a beard
go I'm so excited for dune you're a part
of it what can you tease people oh god
no I'm so excited for dude he can't talk
about it now I'm talking about it jenny
is such an amazing director and he was
great in Blade Runner and oh my god he's
only made great movies I'm really
excited for this was great can we - it's
everyone in Hollywood but you yeah I
could say for sure I'm not in it